welcome back to the show let's get right
back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
starting with our caller from the three
four seven area code who's calling today
from three four seven hi this is Eddie
from Harlem hey Eddie what's going on I
was anyway great man
I've been Washington for the I mean
watching for the last three years thank
you for the bow all right um my question
is if Champa loses in 2020 don't you
think his influence on the Republican
Party is going to be there long after
he's gone yes a little powwow yep you
know he will have the influence of the
voters his base bill I mean he I think
it's a little bit more nuanced it's not
that once Trump is gone so at some point
Trump's going to be gone it could be in
2020 could be 2024 I don't think it's
that Trump is personally going to
maintain influence over voters I just
think that the Trump efficacious of the
Republican Party is going to persist for
a long time the idea that it's fine to
have I mean listen with George W Bush
was no genius but with Donald Trump the
idea that it's fine to have a completely
ignorant person of economics diplomacy
just everything that that's okay that
it's okay to have candidates that speak
to others in the way that Donald Trump
does that do policy by tweet I think
those like the corsa nning of the dialog
is what the affect of Donald Trump is
going to be beyond Trump it's not so
much that Trump will influence voters
it's that he's influenced the Republican
Party yeah but what if we had this news
network it's possible I mean I don't
know he's yeah he's promoting Oh a n
more and more and I wouldn't be
surprised to see once Trump is gone
whenever that is from office getting
more involved with with Oh a n which he
just seems to be just thrilled with as I
predicted he would be four months ago
but yeah maybe he would look at starting
a network maybe not I mean the if he
gets reelected he's going to be almost
80 year
when he's out of office and maybe he's
just gonna retire one quick thing well
your thoughts about Trump's tweet about
Fox News today didn't see it what'd he
say
um he's saying that maybe they should go
all the way left and we and maybe foxy
mystical 200 again oh did he actually do
that this week yes did not see that but
not surprised and makes make I'm
doubling down then on what I just said I
look forward to your video about that
all right thanks really appreciate the
call thank you David
take care yep